the process of making art is essentially
taking an inward journey outwardly allow
me to explain when people take an inward
journey through any kind of
contemplative practice whether it's a
meditative state catalyzed by TM or
whether it's psychedelic assisted
psychotherapy it is said that when it
will take these in more journeys you
have to provide a safe space you have to
hold space for the person you have to
basically protect the person from the
outside world they have to be free from
having to manage external concerns so
that they feel safe enough to take a
journey in a world right and so the
orientation of the mind can shift from
Darwinian survival based orientation to
a more contemplative poetic whimsical
and creative
state of being
mode of perception and so we take these
inward attorneys and we come out of the
experience usually inspired cleansed
detoxified connected to something larger
than ourselves freed from the burdens of
everyday living and all this is good
that's why they say meditation is so
good for you right there's a host of
cognitive benefits associated with
taking inward journeys with day dreamy
with forest bathing with losing
ourselves with surrendering to the
moment etc etc etc
but most of these inward journeys are
had in private
you have the contemplative
transformation attorney within maybe you
might come out of that
olan integrate the experience fine but
what if I was to propose that there is a
third way there is another kind of inner
journey that can be expressed outwardly
you still need to meet the same criteria
you need still need to hold space you
still need to protect yourself from the
concerns of the everyday you have to
shield yourself from the world something
that works really well I think is a
beautiful a perfect landscape with
nobody around because what happens then
is the inner journey can be expressed
elderly and you can actually appropriate
the landscape into your inward journey
you can use cues from the environment to
actually orient your meditative journey
the journey within and the journey
without bleed into each other you cross
the streams you fuse cognition and dream
you enter the imaginal reality but it's
expressed outwardly you don't do it with
your eyes closed you do it with your
eyes open and I think that these poetic
reveries these poetic trances that we
that are essentially again inward
journeys expressed outwardly can be used
for the purposes of art for the verbal
purposes of poetry they can be used to
express and articulate ineffable States
right it is during the poetic trance
that you can see the world in the grain
of sand and heaven in a wild flower and
hold infinity in the palm of your hand
and hold eternity in an hour that is
only possible when your unbounded in
your inward journey and you express that
outwardly
you are free from the constraints of
self you are having a mystical
experience you are having oceanic
consciousness all of that is happening
right the hallmark of a contemplative
practice but it's happening outwardly
it's a creative way of actually
documenting the inward experience
outwardly so that it can be shared it's
a way of turning the mind inside out as
it's in flight and I think this is the
essence of creativity this is where the
artists go this is the poetic trance
this is a transitory state of
enchantment
[Music]
this is when
all of our realities become dreams and
win all of our dreams become realities
and then at the end you have a work of
art right you have something that you
can behold you have your ecstatic
painting you have the song recorded and
people can marvel why do we marvel at
this art because my friends the
transcendent shines through the mattes
it partially articulated form the
sublime shines through people recognize
great art implicitly because they can
see the infinite expressed intangible
bounded form the artist contends with
the unknown was the unbounded and he
reigns it in fits it in a frame
that is the insurrection that is the
creative exorcism that is the creative
art the creative act
[Music]